this is an interesting moment on Monday
president Trump said that people and you
know we've been watching the state of
the union's addresses you know I've been
watching them most of my life and it's a
tradition when you're talking about
partisan issues if it's Republican
president the Democrats don't clap if
it's a Democratic president Republicans
don't cry it's the way it always is
President Trump said that the Democrats
who were not clapping
during his stay the Union address were
treasonous and were guilty of treason
people lost their minds then the next
day the White House said no he was
joking do you have a take on whether he
was joking or not I I think he's usually
a joke and that's part of the problem is
that we have you know this is a
character test for the country though I
mean since he came down that escalator
the day of his announcement Melania came
down and actually the way the founding
fathers wanted it exactly and you know
he has figured out a way to insult and
to offend and to demean almost every
kind of American from you know veterans
black people doesn't matter what it is
and unfortunately though he's a DD and
now we're getting a DD we you know we we
now follow him all over the place and I
think it's important for us to say
listen he gets to run the White House he
doesn't get to run my house I am gonna
continue being a good person I'm gonna
take care of my kids I'm gonna be good
to people with no matter who they vote
for and we we can't let the president
become the precedent for the way that we
behave yes
yeah I'm genuinely so jealous I've tried
to get him to tweet at me so many times
but he really actually likes me because
he loves Big Bang Theory so is a big fan
of yours
you